[Musique]
mars c'est la journée internationale des
droits des femmes vont refaire deux
points ce soir sur la place des femmes
dans le marché de l'emploi avec noomi m6
pdg de l'institut du québec bonsoir ça
vous avez préparé plusieurs graphiques
pour regarder un peu la place des femmes
dans le marché de l'emploi on va
commencer tout de suite par le taux
d'emploi au début de la pandémie on a
quand même eu une chute importante bien
sûr du taux d'emploi un peu partout dans
la société mais particulièrement et
notamment chez les femmes est ce qu'on
est revenu au niveau d'avant temps des
mets pas tout à fait au tout donc comme
on voit les femmes ont été
particulièrement touchées pendant la
pandémie parce qu'elle était dans des
secteurs qui ont été plus touchés par
les restrictions sanitaires ou plus de
contacts physiques comme en santé par
exemple tutorat avec le public donc plus
à risque les mères monoparentales
convient par exemple quand les écoles ou
les garderies ont dû fermer ont dû
rester à la maison pouvait pas aller
travailler mais le rebond était très
fort mais toujours pas au point de nous
ramener aux niveaux de 2010 neuf donc
juste avant la pandémie qui étaient des
taux d'emplois record chez les femmes
est ce ça s'explique en bonne partie par
le fait que c'est surtout les femmes de
55 ans et plus qui sont pas retournés
pleinement sur le marché de l'emploi ok
mais cela dit quand on regarde depuis
les années 70 on voit quand même que le
taux d'emploi est passé de quoi 40 à
presque 60 % de la population exactement
ceci les femmes de 15 ans et plus dont 5
lui comme à l'ensemble de la population
en âge de travailler qu'on regardait
habituellement et on voit que c'est
quand même des progrès phénoménaux qui
s'explique par plusieurs plusieurs
raisons surtout le taux de scolarisation
c'est un déterminant très très très
corrélé au taux d'emplois non plus on
est scolarisé plus notre taux d'emploi
est élevé et les femmes ont vécu
rattrapage impressionnant et nos
politiques familiales aussi au québec
les des politiques familiales les
garderies par exemple ou des congés de
maternité plus généreux que dans
d'autres provinces ou d'autres pays qui
ont permis aux femmes de rester très
active sur le marché du travail est
d'accroître même cette participation
plus qu'ailleurs cela dit l'écart
salarial pionne loi sur l'équité
salariale qui existe au québec cet écart
salarial entre les hommes et les femmes
l'écart n'est pas encore comblé on voit
depuis 1997 on est à 16 % d'écart
favorable aux hommes et là on est à quoi
8 10% est vraiment exactement on y prend
ce moment on est à 9% mais si on regarde
des quelques dernières années on est
autour de 10% et donc oui il ya une
baisse quand même importante mais on
stagne depuis environ cinq ans on voit
qu'il ya très peu d'améliorations au
niveau de l'équité salariale donc même
si des progrès au niveau de l'emploi les
femmes sont beaucoup plus présentes sur
le marché du travail beaucoup plus
scolarisés il ya eu une amélioration
quand même passé de 16 7% autour de 10%
à 20 ans ceux des progrès mais pourquoi
ce stock mais ça stagne on a
probablement eu déjà les principaux
effets de la loi sur l'équité salariale
qui a 25 ans aujourd'hui de l'éducation
et hétéros les principaux gains on les a
obtenues mais depuis cinq à dix ans on a
besoin de faire des efforts beaucoup
plus importants sur l'organisation du
travail
aussi le choix des secteurs les femmes
vont souvent choisir des domaines
d'études ou d'emplois qui vont être
moins bien rémunérés les compétences
numériques par exemple les femmes sont
moins attirés vers développer ce genre
de compétences pu travailler dans les
sciences technologie les systèmes les
fameux système dont on parle mais ils
sont mieux rémunérés en santé ils
sortent un poste de fans qui sont moins
bien rémunérés donc des éléments comme
ça éléphants souvent vont préférer avoir
plus de temps mais pour s'occuper des
enfants restés à la maison donc en plus
de tâches familiales donc au moins une
progression de carrière plus lente et en
beaucoup moins de femmes avec des hauts
revenus donc plusieurs causes qui font
que on a de la misère réduire cet écart
alors on l'expliquent même si on est
probablement d'avis que ce n'est pas
encore acceptable comme situation un
employeur québécois sur cinq n'a pas
encore atteint l'équité salariale
présentement dernier graphique ont
représenté c'est le taux d'activité des
femmes alors le taux d'activité s'est
les personnes en emploi et en recherche
d'emploi par rapport donc à la
population de 15 ans et plus dans ce
cas-ci également le taux d'activité au
québec qui augmente est ce qu'ils
atteignent y stagnent paris on regarde
notamment à cause du vieillissement de
la population
parce qu'il ya plus de plus âgés donc ça
fait que la progression est plus lente
et ça fait ça va rester ça au cours des
prochaines années aussi donc il ya eu
une bon assez important si on se replace
dans le contexte canadien c'est quand
même au québec quel taux de
participation est le plus élevé puis
même qu'on regarde à l'échelle de la
planète on y est un endroit dans le
monde où est ce qu'on a le taux de
participation des femmes le plus élevé
des taux de participation ces deux taux
d'activité également activement donc à
plus de 60 % plus de 60% sa baisse parce
qu'il ya une population qui vieillit
donc si on regarde les 25-54 ans c'est
encore plus élevé puis on se démarque
mais vu que de plus en plus de femmes
qui sont en âge de prendre leur retraite
ça fait baisser le taux d'activité de la
population et donc ça fait que ça stagne
et ça va continuer de stagner mais il ya
quand même des bonnes nouvelles derrière
ça chez les 25-54 ans et à dur ça veut
dire que le taux de participation
continue le taux d'activité continue
d'augmenter ok mais tous les écarts ne
sont pas complètement résorbé entre les
hommes et les femmes non il reste encore
d'importants au niveau de la
rémunération des postes de direction que
les postes dans les conseils
d'administration merci me m6 toujours
très clair merci beaucoup merci pour
voir nos émissions en entier rendez vous
sur la chaîne ici et redit
[Musique]